he's currently being charged a jizya
that's a sharia tax placed in islamic
countries on
infidels except he's not receiving the
fine in islamic country
he's receiving the fine in ontario
canada
the reason he wore his shoes into a
property that he owns when his tenants
were muslim and ontario's human rights
court says that he
is guilty of religious discrimination
assalamu alaikum greetings of
peace what's up guys how are you doing
get ready for my top five reasons
why you'd probably want to reconsider
after watching this wearing shoes in
your house
now one might ask why all of a sudden
are you talking about
shoes and feet eddie well unfortunately
the hate machine is at it again looking
for any sinister way to manufacture
more fear and hate fear mongering is
a major tool they use amongst others the
hate machine it depends and thrives they
salivate on this
on your your ignorance of real authentic
islam
and they capitalize on this taking
advantage of good people
like yourselves they also love making
people in concepts as foreign as
possible for the sake of demonizing them
so to counter the hate and to
make these concepts less foreign and
familiar
i'll be going over my top five
reasons for the no shoes policy on this
week's
show
all right guys you ready you've all by
now heard the common mantra
sharia law it's invading us it's coming
to get you
like martians are coming from mars panic
fear sharia the boogie man
you know and by now if you've been
watching the dean's show sharia ten
commandments
jesus taught shariah is basis basically
god's law
it's very simple but they get you on
this
if you follow me and this next story is
no different
it's very very interesting and that's
why what motivated me
to give you these top five reasons why
you should reconsider wearing shoes in
the house
now about the story in short it has to
do with a landlord
and a muslim tenant the landlord was
refusing to take off his shoes in a
muslim person's house
where they pray and wasn't giving them
the five minute heads up they were
requesting before opening the door since
he says he already gave him the 24-hour
notice
they also found him making a derogatory
joke about muslims on his facebook page
there's more to the story i'm sure but
at the end they all
went to the court and the court found
the landlord guilty of violating the
tenant laws
a fine was issued that's another
discussion if it was too high
or what the real issue is how you know
see the real issue is
how sinister you know the hate
provocateurs
as they're running with this and calling
it see
calling it sharia law tax fine sharia is
coming
exploiting the whole situation just
really ridiculous things
being said help him cover his 12
thousand dollar sharia tax and i'm not
going to get into dissecting the whole
story
the whole situation on what happened you
think that you think they really care
about this landlord
they're just they're just seizing the
opportunity salivating for this
opportunity and they got it
for another opportunity to fearmonger
and spread hate
you see when it comes to justice islam
doesn't look at your color
religion status islam calls for justice
no matter
what you are just look at the passage
from the quran they put it up
in the harvard university because it's
so
powerful we have to be just against
ourselves against our
we have to be on the side of justice and
god loves the just
now back to what happened i just want to
clarify a couple concepts for example
the
five-minute request they made a big
stink
as to the husband wanting five minutes
to make sure his wife is modestly
dressed
and apparently the wife heba is male
needed extra time so she could be
modestly dressed
hey apparently it takes a lot of effort
to don
that full islamic beekeeper suit
beekeeper suit
beekeeper suit even though she was
unemployed and
was always at home or they are not
praying
they got the 24 notice you might say so
it's okay that within the 24 hour period
the doors can just
open in strangers can just walk in maybe
your wife
just getting out of the shower half
naked
you yourself as well you can appreciate
a heads
up why the stink it's
it's really about humans working
together common respect
for each other and being genuine and
sincere in that you know you put
yourself in that situation someone that
makes a small request
you can generally appreciate when they
do and you work together and you avoid
the bigger problems that can come from
not respecting each other
and working together now the other
concept they're in a hysteria over is
the shoes
and this leads us to the question why do
muslims take off their shoes in their
homes or places of worship you might ask
so here's my top five reasons
to make this less foreign to you and
more familiar
number one because the gentleman's a
christian so obviously he doesn't remove
the shoes when he goes into the house
that is something of the muslim
tradition the muslim people
as muslims i want to start off by saying
that we love
moses and jesus and when you read the
bible you see them
clearly being told to take off their
shoes the shoe policy might
you might call it it reads in the bible
when moses
is being told by god did not come any
closer god said take off your sandals or
shoes
for the place you are standing is holy
ground this is in exodus
3 5. or how about in exodus 40 31
where it describes moses and aaron and
his sons and how they used to
wash their hands and feet
before prayer did you know that there
are over
two dozen references in this verse
they're also being told to take off
their shoes
before they pray to make evolution
and to prepare themselves and did you
know that there are over two dozen
verses
referring to taking off the shoes in the
bible this is
something i call the again the no shoe
policy and
i i want you to know that the same way
abraham moses
jesus and prophet muhammad last and
final messenger they all washed up and
prayed
the same way as we're doing today
obeying god
you see it's becoming more familiar
right and less foreign
so less fear now let's say you were
outside for example
you have a clean area maybe it's
freezing wet and you don't want to take
your shoes off it's very cold or
whatever
your shoes are clean you can pray in
them there's a hadith related to this
directly
that's not the point i'm not going to
get into the thick of praying with your
shoes
i'm well aware of it remember i'm just
breaking down this concept and helping
our brothers and sisters in humanity
to see the logic in this and
they'll start to see this as less
foreign
so less room for demonizing this is
exactly what the people with hate in
their hearts
want to do and do let me give you number
two did you know that there is a
pesticide study released by the epa it
tells us that pesticides from lawns can
remain there up until a week
and then you walk on it with your shoes
so not only are you tracking potentially
animal feces dirt sand germs and
whatever else is dirty under the sun
but also poisons into your homes on the
bottom of your shoes
that can also cause potential harm to
your children and pets
who are always playing on the floors
let's move on to number three
while wearing shoes in your home you're
tracking in
dirt and filth into your homes on the
floors
also some people roll around on their
beds with their shoes
i want you just to just think about
where those shoes have been
what a person might have stepped on the
kind of germs you're also exposing a
small baby your child to
who's always crawling on the floor the
floor
is their exploring ground their ocean
their oasis
of a playground that you're
contaminating with the
dirty shoes and you don't even want to
take them off because of
sharia now how ignorant do you sound
repeating
that ignorant hate rhetoric try going to
a traditional
let's say japanese restaurant or
japanese person's home an
asian person or a whole culture of
people that are not muslim
that take off their shoes how about many
holistic
doctors people should remove their shoes
when they enter the home
because if you think about what you walk
around
all day long on the outside of your home
you're walking across people's grass
or maybe across a park picking up
pesticides
that people have sprayed you're walking
across other people's at work
carpet or flooring and you pick up
toxins on your shoes
and then you come home and you walk
around your house
and those toxins accumulate in your home
we know from studies done on carpet dust
and on from
dust bunnies like on hardwood floors
that there's
actually solvents and pesticides that
were not
sprayed or used in a person's home found
in their home
and so the theory being that it was
tracked in from the outside
who make you take off their shoes
because they are more in their offices
because they are more open-minded and
educated to these facts
tell them that i'm not going to take off
my shoes because of sharia and your
religion
i'm just going to stand here with all my
shoes and come in your home my office
okay how about how about we work
together okay how about we work together
after
you you leave let let's do this what you
go ahead and remove your shoes or you
scrub the floor how about that
let's work together look i just cleaned
the floor
when you leave you clean the floor after
me how about that or just
uh booties they have these booties you
put on
on your feet how about that how about
shower cap you can put a shower cap see
solutions we're working together plastic
over the shoes
see it's it's about hygiene in islam
there's a
very strong emphasis on cleanliness my
friends
that's what that's what it's about
cleanliness
maybe next i'll give you the top five
reasons why
we clean with water after we use the
toilet
imagine if you went out to get the the
morning's paper
and by accident there was dog poo
dog poo on the newspaper and now you
touched it and got on your hand and now
it's on your hand
so you you you what do you do you wipe
it or you wash it off
you're a smart person you you wash or
you wipe and wash
because no matter how much you wipe it
you're not gonna get rid of the filthy
smell so we wash with water
i'm going off on a tangent on another
thing another concept so we wash with
water just as a side note because who
knows
what the hate machine might do next and
go after this
and the headlines will read muslim
sharia
taking over bathrooms water vessels now
in bathrooms
you'll leave that but we'll leave that
for for another show maybe if you'd like
i can make the top three or five
on on this but let's move along to
number four
number four let's see less constant
cleaning
i mean vacuuming dusting for all that
dirt and germ sand and only god knows
what other
what else you're bringing to the house
from the petrol gas
you might have just stepped on while
filling up gas at the gas station
or that contamination you stepped all
over on at the same gas station bathroom
how about the feces in yours you don't
notice at the bottom of your shoes from
the same gas station's bathroom that's
nasty
how about all the extra wear and tear on
your carpets how about that one from
your shoes scratching up the floors
from those same shoes especially the
high-heeled ones or the heavy those
heavy-duty ones with the heavy rubber
soles
so when you've invested so much money
in a good floor or a carpet why not
preserve it
makes sense doesn't it and protect it
from the extra wear and tear from those
little rocks
and pebbles they'll get into at the
stuck in the bottom the grooves
the bottom of your shoes that damage the
floor
there's a big difference between a house
where you have
shoes versus no shoes let's go let me
give you one more
and that's it for this week's show it's
just so much more comfortable
and relaxing with no shoes just
make sure your socks and feet are clean
keep good hygiene
but maybe you've got other issues oh
if you're if your feet are always stink
so now you're complaining about muslims
and sharia islam blah blah blah
but the real issue is maybe you just got
stinky feet
that's it clean those sticky feet keep
keep clean socks
don't hide those dirty feet and socks in
the shoes
take off your shoes in the house to
protect yourself and your children from
all the germs dirt and fill
but hey hey look let's be fair if you
want to wear your shoes in your home
it's your home i'm not going to
disrespect you
i'm not going to fear monger over you
look it's your home
bring in as much dirt as you please but
now that you see the logic
behind why we take off our shoes show a
little respect
courtesy and kindness and please and
please take off your shoes and stop
making a big deal manipulating the
people
clean your feet and more importantly
then clean feet is a clean heart let's
fix our hearts from all this
hate and bigotry that's being projected
out from what's corrupted
inside the heart now be remiss
if i didn't share with you that the only
way
to truly clean the heart is by
connecting
it to the owner of the heart and
worshiping that creator of your heart
alone not his creation abraham
moses jesus and the final messenger sent
to mankind the prophet muhammad peace be
upon them all they did it
they all called people to be the best to
their neighbors as jesus said
when he was asked what's the greatest
commandment jesus responded
you shall have no other gods but the one
god hear o israel
the lord thy god is one and after that
love your neighbor these haters keep
missing the main message
worship god alone worship the creator
not the creation know god
love god obey god and be good to your
neighbor
and help spread goodness peace and love
in the world not hate i love you guys
that's why i'm here sharing this message
thank you very much
for tuning in every week we're here in
the dean show i didn't have a guess but
i
wanted to prepare this for you and i
hope you got to benefit subscribe if you
hadn't already and
we started with peace look look if you
have any questions you sincerely you
tuned in you want to know
look before you know we many people they
they out of ignorance out of fear and
that hatred we're talking about
they leave some nasty comments they say
some ignorant things why not make the
human connection
maybe visit with a muslim adamas call us
call
be courageous enough to pick up the
phone it's simple from your
home office 1-800-662
islam spark up a conversation ask those
tough questions
but make the human connection before you
write that bad comment
that vile this is look the more noble
route to go
that route is easy cursing profanity
acting in a derogatory manner
why not make the connection you don't
know i'm telling you what goodness
what doors of goodness can open
guaranteed you got to be sincere and
genuine and tune in here every week to
the dean show
tune in i'll see you next time subscribe
if you haven't already thank you very
much god bless you peace be with you
assalamu
you